[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
c'est chaud ça oui et loire
combat il
merci maman a tort sur leurs tables en
bois zone est ce que j'ai dit au plaisir
moi aussi chez la première de ta
première magnifique
vous savez que j'étais jeune je sais
qu'ils veulent absolument mais je vous
ai parlé sur les bancs oui on sait qu'un
des trois secondes mais bon c'est pas
nouveau mais malheureusement c'est
triste conçoivent a vu un
mais oui parce que je suis juste monté
pour m'a fait plaisir de revoir mes
jeunes mais je me rends compte
oui parce que moi j'ai à vous buvez
koala de champagne madame une petite
cherchant parmi mes tripes que moi
j'habitais à chamonix quand j'étais
petit chai et mon père travaille au
tunnel sous le mont blanc fait la
construction et honnête sur mon bureau
et j'avais souvent à megève
j'étais par tour mais hélas j'ai trouvé
ça génial on s'est beaucoup battu pas ce
qu'est le monde voulait absolument pas
de grandes constructions il voulait que
les chats les restes de petits chalets
et qu'il y ait cette ambiance cette
atmosphère petit village crois qu'on a
réussi donc c'est très bien réussi j'ai
vu ce que c'était le mont d'arbois là
tous et tous ces arbres ont été plantés
et tout ça alors ça c'est ma dernière
qui a planté tous à 1924 lorsqu'elle a
acheté tous été vain elle s'est dit on
va leur faire quelque chose au départ
étant si jamais dit
alors dites moi si je me suis pas trompé
on est quoi je vous ai mis à ma droite
de 4-2-4 ya pas de la maîtresse de
maison n'est pas l'art non bon alors
donc vous recevez oui absolument
à ma droite oui dans les abers hansen
ici oui robert hossein oui marie
stéphane bernard qui tu ne vous la
connaissez que tu me conta trice très
très simple et absolument aller elles
joueront les scénarii je l'aimé un peu
au bout
oui mais pourquoi elle peut au bout
comme les grandes gueules pas me
fatiguer fume le cigare attaques hacker
martin assouline
oui charmante qui a fait ce bouquin sur
le questionnaire de proust en effet de
prouver la femme ne connais pas je
connais son mari jacques garcia henry
jean servat
ça va très bien jean-rémy monsieur
garcia à côté de marisa d'accord ok et
on met on inverse
henry jean servat et d'aliments voilà
vous arrivez de houla et moscou vous
aurez c'est pas vrai nom j'arrive de
moscou parce que je vais peut-être
ouvrir là bas petit restaurant fromage
fromage français bien et du le vert
rothschild
voilà très simple très simple une toute
petite chose
vous connaissiez edouard stern vous le
c'est moi qui ai fait son mariage
absolument il était fou amoureux de
béatrice et au départ ils n'ont pas
voulu se marier elle s'est mariée entre
temps et il m'a dit écoute soit gentil
tu m'a vite à la chasse vite béatrice
c'était en autriche et sont tombés
amoureux l'un de l'autre ce qu'ils
étaient puisque sa durée puisque même
après continuellement bien là faisaient
tous deux chez ces charmantes
ils ont eu trois enfants superbe qu'est
ce qui s'est passé je comprends pas je
comprends pas parce qu'ils étaient
remarquablement intelligent mais ce qui
n'avait pas vécu suffisamment sa vie de
garçon vous savez ça use
à quel âge ils avaient quand tu
m'épouser des aspérités il n'affichait
pas il était chef
c'est elle c'est ça je crois qu'il a
voulu tout à coup et puis c'est quand on
a tellement d'argent faut être un âne
équilibre mais alors absolument nous
sommes oui pour soi oui bonsoir johnny
cash s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
je
oui
madame monsieur bonsoir dieu
m les roannais
parmi vous
oui la quinine d'abord la chambre et la
tour noire
c'est le voeu c'est le chocolat au lait
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait toujours
toujours toujours les mousses au
chocolat noir moi j'aime le chocolat au
lait j'en ai donc eu envie de le voir
comment ça va super à part par les
années qui passent mais non elle passe
pas mais en général on l'a dit et c'est
un os x mais non ils s'y fit savoir
s'occuper puis voilà vous êtes en bonne
santé
santé mais non comment est ce qu'on peut
entendre une chose pareille trop bonne
cette année c'est pas parce que quand
même toi tu est l'incarnation de 68 etc
sinon 68 non je suis j'ai fait partie
des quelques rares qui n'ont pas occupé
l'odéon le raconte dans mon spectacle
l'aider et fit un peu grasse sans la
moindre poignées d'amour parce que ça
existe vous avez la peau y ait de
l'amour c'est délicieux et à vous avez
des filles sont un peu grasse qui n'ont
pas de poignées d'amour qui essayait
d'entrer dans les robes de scènes de
madeleine renaud avait volé dans les 68
et elle déchire et les roms et madeleine
était là elle pleurait et barreaux il
avait le menton guy tremblay l'avait son
petit costard il y avait un américain
torse nu qui avait arraché une photo de
barreaux dans son bureau et qui lui
crachent à la gueule en disant barre
horizontale ballo izem ouais c'est là et
moi j'étais là pour essayer de
de ramener à la raison les comédiens de
la troupe du premier magic circus parce
qu'on était invité en angleterre il est
l afg la révolution et finalement j'en
ai récupéré deux je suis parti comme
victor hugo en exil angleterre vous
savez qu'en mai 68 devant le palais des
papes des comédiens et comédien ils
étaient plusieurs centaines crier
villard béjart salazar même salopards il
comparaît vilar au dictateur mort tué
cet hôtel csss et il est vrai oui mais
on est mort dominique avait dit en fait
les vrais prolétaires dans tout ça c'est
les crs tu sais ce qu'ils criaient les
crs qui répondait non étudiants dian
dian alors mari stéphane et la future
veuve joyeuse de l'opéra comique c'est
gai non nous en avons trois ou quatre ce
qui ce qui vous menacent tous où tout
surtout mesdames c'est déjà fait
malheureusement vous êtes vous après ces
joyeux mais je suis restée joyeuse
exemple sur vous n'êtes en hommage aux
marines et fin il faut être joyeux
écouter on a reçu tellement de bonheur
qu'on peut pas lui faire cette offense
non mais c'est vrai il m'a tellement
gâtés dans la vie j'ai tout reçu deux
secteurs
c'est fantastique
un bon j'espère que mes vols seront
joyeuse bozena et combien ça vous en
aurez compris à part deux ou trois et
vous vous arrêtez la médecine et vous
vous êtes connu quand vous avez fait la
vie parisienne ensemble et chanteuse
sociétaires à l'opéra comique devenu
sociétaire mais elle chante très très
bien et surtout aux comics je prends des
chanteuses qui peuvent chanter six fois
par semaine vous savez à l'opéra il y
dénonce à jour sur deux et nous ces
normes stop
alors elle est là un organe c'est à se
demander si ce n'est pas un travelo
parce que ça se passe bien la vie
d'artiste heures ça se passe très bien
ziani sa fille sur scène un bonheur
c'est un petit spectacle de cabaret de
musicaux et vous l'avez pour plusieurs
années l'opéra-comique oui bah oui j'ai
vient d'être nommé là pour s'y rendre il
est possible que ce soit forcé de m'en
aller
dans trois ans parce que vous savez et
et à salses et intérêts sera tiré le
général de gaulle voulait virer le
le président de la rtf de l'époque dont
jean minois à 65 dont j'ai oublié le nom
et comme c'était un compagnon de la
libération est un ami de gaulle ne
pouvait pas le virer et sur puce et donc
il avait promulgué une loi qui disait
qu'à partir de 65 ans on ne peut plus de
diriger un établissement public
c'est arrivé à michèle cotta c'était
bien dommage du gala à l'opéra et
beaucoup d'autres on va un site c'est
très bizarre parce que il n'ya pas de
limite d'âge pour le président de la
république ni pour le ministre il y en a
pour les artistes ce qui est vraiment
c'est comme dire à picasso à 65 ans tu
arrêtes de de faire de la peinture et
vous savez qu'il ya eu un drame
incroyable ces montagnes et quand même
qui est l'inventeur du l'inventeur du
sida et le jour de ses 65 ans avec quel
jus et plein de recherche à faire encore
pour lui et monsieur vous ne pouvez plus
entrer dans votre laboratoire est arrivé
partir l'amérique
je me suis commence à papa qui la papaye
de montagne et ce qu'il a donné au pape
pendant des années des années c'était
crédit agricole est elle sérieuse rue il
ya un truc avec les super risque est
très bien je sais qu'ils ont plein de
technique pour mourir plus tard
la caresse la promesse du monde ni les
femmes les traits nos désirs fous qui
vous dit des mois puisque je suis à vous
oh là là là là que je vous pose une
colle mais je vous donne pas la réponse
karine parce que c'est pas c'est pas con
dame
vous savez qu'une caisse qu'utilisait
mistinguett pour se démaquiller atteint
déjà laissé sur ma vie authentique les
urines
non car ça brûle à manger pas jamais
essayé
prisonnier c'est un point qui pose
encore c'est que ça doit être bizarre
bonsoir bonsoir nous sommes des gens
très très chic nous l'ont dit
alors nous nous attendons au quatrième
étage
elle se démaquille au sperme
[Musique]
némale
tandis qu'ali
[Musique]
m
faux
et l'incroyable marie marquée elle même
l'a écrit dans ses mémoires grande
tragédienne robert les premiers allez
marisa elle se mettait un cornichon je
n'y vis pas ou si l on soit avantagé
montargis mosshart et vous bien il est
monté à pied
[Musique]
g
plaisant ça va bien
bonsoir bonsoir allez-y je connais la
maison est bien sûr très heureux de vous
connaître en fait on se connaît pas je
vous admire évidemment beaucoup de gens
heureux de vous rencontrer
est ce que tu as fait exprès de laisser
la porte de sa chambre à coucher ouverte
pour marisa c'est en fait n'a dit non
après après d'après ce que des rumeurs
thierry a pris une veste parce que vous
avez vu la rangée de weis qui assure le
lien que ça tu meurs
une chambre picotte
les gens me cocotte avec des costumes
donne c'est très spécial finalement lors
dé renier la seconde tu veux rémy mais
je suis allé parce que je connais la
famille depuis toujours et d'une manière
tellement extraordinaire et original et
je les aime beaucoup beaucoup et je vais
vous dire pourquoi
d'abord parce que lorsque j'ai lu c'est
épouvantable accident que vous savez je
fais pas relater ici
enfin on s'est retourné beaucoup
d'aisance h robert une action de
voitures terrifiant il ya une vingtaine
d'années un peu plus 25 ans et la femme
craque elle est vive et qui était sa
famille dans l'accident à jour du bios
voilà aujourd hui de se marier elle est
morte dans l'accident est à nous d envoi
du rentre-dedans beau et c'est elle qui
conduisait est alors enfin que tu es
cogiter à l'hosto la première personne
des premières qui est venu me voir
j'étais complètement toucher ni j'avais
demandé commanderait sur mon lit en face
pouvait plus on était dans un état
s'était grace kelly
elle est venue avec des confitures et
avec ses enfants magnifiques et tout est
à partir de ce moment la halle s'est
inquiété cetera et elle est venue assez
souvent et ensuite j'ai été présenté
dans courtoise et puis ensuite on est
restés tous tous très amis les enfants
venez nous voir répéter au théâtre et à
oui c'est une vraie
de langlade qui nice qu'il s'est jamais
départi là et je crois pouvoir dire que
j'ai vu le prince qui est cette chance
juste avant sa mort puisque j'étais je
présidais le festival du siècle dernier
robert toi qui les connaît bien et va se
marier j'espère je suis certain qu'il va
se marier
je suis d'accord pour l'épouser je ne
suis pas sûr que vous soyez sur le titre
à la libye ce serait bien la science si
j'ose dire on est il trouvera non parce
que je vais très honnête on l'a vu
beaucoup beaucoup sortir avec des tas de
jeunes femmes et qui était ravissante
debock beaucoup de mannequins d hier
mais je pense que je ne sais pas si des
résultats cérémonie il était d'ailleurs
bouleversé tous les trois et très
émouvoir formidable et lui est devenu
quelqu'un de tout soudain tout d'elle
il va assumer complètement et je connais
des à des gens auxquels il va s'entourer
de 100 tours qui vont ils font le
pouvoir retrouver de camilla c'est sûr
ça c'est touchant son mariage m
finalement tout le monde
tout le monde a bavé là dessus je trouve
ça assez souche entre les deux vieux
amants qui finissent par ce que ces
choix tous à quelque chose de wes était
finalement
ce qui est horrible ce qui est horrible
c'est qu'il a fallu attendre si
longtemps pour se marier ils sont vieux
tous les deux et je ne suis pas d'accord
enfin je trouve qu'elle voulait me faire
un mariage comme ça sur la tombe de
quand même je trouve ça moche ça vous
choque terriblement les gosses et les
gosses qui sont obligés d'assister à ce
mariage de sourire d'être heureux non
moi je trouve ça là non excusez moi ce
qui n'aurait pas le droit qui la menace
elle est capable de tout mais je suis
d'accord qu'il attend du bien mais il ne
lui donnait pas mettre ces deux fonds
non mais là je vous ai sa femme il a
épousé sa mère c'est pas pareil jusqu'au
c'est à la fois ridicule et touchant
parce que ridicule il est chef de
l'église anglicane mais j'arrive à
lettres du moins donc il est divorcé il
épouse une bourse et à ce niveau-là ça
c'est pas bien c'est au niveau du
protocole la loi tout ça dans la
séparation des églises et l'état écoute
il est chef de l'église
enfin il va être chef de l'église
anglicane qu'en dise carrément
l'angleterre il est divorcé pour une
divorcée mais au choco thierry a raison
c'est tellement ridicule que sont finis
par année touchant pitoyable et touchant
jusqu'aux c'est à la fois ridicule et
touchant je pense que quand edmond de
rothschild baron et demande roger alice
et d'épouser la petite starlette
l'habitat triste vedette kate est made
in italy je pense que dans suivi les
lieux dans sa famille dans son monde
à mon avis ça parce que vous êtes devenu
au delà la cat essence du chic absolu il
ya nadine de rothschild mais à l'origine
est que pour sa famille pour lui c'est
un roman d'amour jusqu'au boutiste et
voulais s'était il a permis à vous
imposer c'était pas facile
mais trêve quand même oui bonsoir
bonsoir martin a souligné jacques garcia
au quatrième étage je suis désolé je
suis allé jusqu'au bout de mon ambition
est de mon amour j'estime que si diana
avait tenu à vraiment pour ses enfants
uniquement pour les enfants moi je
n'aurais jamais laissé ma place j'ai
jamais derrière
[Musique]
je
bonsoir bonsoir soissons
voulait me confier directement passer
d'abord par ici
merci si vous en prie
en tout plus de jouer dos et même j'ai
demandé l'autorisation soir
sa in associé à thierry on étend sur le
protocole j'avais déjà vérifié ce plan
table avec nadine
est ce que c'est bien que je vous fasse
je vous laisse passer devant où j'aurai
du mois devant vous
[Musique]
bon alors marisa ici à ma gauche je suis
bien normalement c'est vous qui a soigné
les gens la ligne par da rocha nantes où
le mec c'est moi le maître de maison
[Musique]
ce sont les gens licenciés ne sait rien
c'est aussi vous êtes l'avancé tout bon
d'une magnifique et afin de me prosper
et prospère mais je les aime beaucoup
prospère ça va tu es là alors je suis là
tu es là robert ici ici robert
[Musique]
moi j'ai une belle histoire avec l'hôtel
lambert j'étais tout jeune et
marie-hélène de rothschild et guy de
rothschild venait de racheter l'hôtel
lambert et puis un jour je veux opus un
matin j'ai pleuvait à verse
je rentre dans un stand pour m'abriter
et là il y avait une caisse grande comme
ça avec 10 carats c'est un début de
romance a dit carafe
je tire une carafe comme ça et puis je
vois une vague couronne il pleuvait
j'avais la plus sur la tête une vague
couronne jeudi combien est le type me
dis un truc idiot jan 10 francs je dis
si je vous prends les dix carafe combien
diba 50 francs mais dans ces proportions
là finalement j'achète les carafes la
pluie cesse j'amène les carafes dans les
stands des stands un copain à côté je
tire une carafe et je vois les armes de
louis philippe couronne royale la totale
château deux châteaux des tueurs externe
je me précipite chez john hamm et je lui
dis mais vous savez je suis marchands de
vaisselle nous en avait pas d'autres you
lalalala m'en parlait pas j'ai la cour
de man pavillon k alors jugé mais c'est
incroyable comment vous avez ça on à
vider des caves dans le marais et
c'était tout l'héritage donc j'ai acheté
l'ensemble de la vaisselle
passé la porte d orléans
et c'est à l'ensemble de la famille
d'orléans car l'hôtel lambert
appartenait avant d'un touriste qui est
la princesse zardari ce qui est à niort
les embraque ans il ya un style que
j'aimais beaucoup et je savais pas ce
que c'était
c'est terrible j'arrivais pas à nommer
le style que j'aime et quand j'allais au
royal lieu qu'angel dans des endroits
comme ça ou à la nouvelle eve
il y avait déjà des choses que j'aime et
je savais pas de nommer en fait celle-ci
quarante et un jour je suis tombé sur un
livre le style des années 40 mais je me
suis rendu compte que tout ce que
j'aimais les meubles en miroir les
choses comme ça c'était le style 40 et à
partir de là je suis devenu dingue du
cil 40 c'est très particulier style car
andres qu il ya eu plusieurs styles en
il ya eu aussi un gilbert de 40 ans dans
l'occupation et les modistes faisait des
des collections les le prêt-à-porter la
haute couture même les talons compensés
en bois tu sais pourquoi je pense qu'ils
avaient pour quand on regarde le c40 que
tu connais sûrement évidemment c'est que
en fait comme la france était occupée
souterrainement que ce soit au théâtre
ce soit au cinéma que ce soit dans la
décoration dans le mobilier les gens
essayer de faire passer une certaine
idée de la france
le style 40 pas semblé très inspirée du
style restauration directoire parce
qu'avec cette idée quand même qu'on
était français qui ont été occupées mais
que malgré tout donc il ya un côté très
axé aussi le modernisme la france est
très français parce qu'on n'a en
revanche filtré français mais on
revendiquait vraiment c'est en fait avec
les années 50 que l'américain a débordé
avec des créations
tu fais quoi jacques en ce moment là je
suis en brune ali les frais en ont l'âge
on a je vais faire quelque chose qui me
tient à coeur parce que c'est un endroit
que j'ai toujours aimé et qui en a je
crois un grand besoin je refais la
mamounia
mais j'y étais il ya un an ça c'est
quand même bon il ya du boulot parce que
moi j'ai connu la mamounia en 65 dans
before before travaux c'était incroyable
et évidemment ça c'est bon ça c'est en
s'agrandissant peut pas dire que ça
s'est arrangé puisque c'est quand même
un symbole du maroc c'est mondialement
connu quand on pense maroc on pense
mamounia province maroc on pense
marrakech montauban du braquage sont pas
passées comme ça s'est inscrit comme ça
oui c'est bien bon c'est évidemment ça
chante si tu peux même temps c'est très
long très rapide avant ouais rapide
enfin on va essayer de le faire
rapidement ont d'abord il ya des équipes
il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour
il faut fermer à huy a pas le choix à
ses pendants combinaison permet ça la
grande discussion c'est un mois à quatre
mois ou une fois sept mois dans un dîner
comme ça un soir il y avait une rame
très chic qui était à table comme ça on
ne peut plus agressive hiver alors vous
faites la maison du sultan de brunei
alors moi oui bon d'accord
et puis elle me fait vous devez
certainement mettre les robinetteries en
or et je lui ai répondu mais vous
connaissez un meilleur support pour les
pierres précieuses
quand tu viennes sultan de brunei que tu
avais eu affaire à lui ou à son
secrétaire dans l'invisible lui tu le
voyais mains d'argile de trois contacts
il faut non contrairement à d'autres
clients importants comme ça où j'ai
vraiment eu de contact direct
aujourd'hui ou capacités mais j'ai eu de
contacts directs mais on raconte que le
fameux hôtel particulier de la place
vendôme n'est jamais venu ou une fois
non mais bien souvent il ya eu des
grands soucis dès qu'il a eu fini il a
eu un problème terrible c'est que je
crois qu'il avait un peu pris dans la
caisse de l'état d'après ce que j'ai
comme monde parce que c'est pas le
sultan c'est le frère du sultan et
soi-disant l'hôtel était fait pour le
sultan hockey des choses un peu
compliquées finalement le sultan est
venu souvent mais le sultan une
nombreuse famille avec plusieurs femmes
qui tombent et issa rien à d'entrée oui
tout à fait c'était la pire affaire de
ma vie sur la mort ancien un convoi
parce que j'étais trop jeune que je
n'avais pas la maîtrise de ce genre
d'histoire et que finalement j'avais pas
maîtriser la masse de nora qu'il fallait
demander un
en compensation de la masse d'heure des
gens que moi j'employais fini c'est fini
c'est dit c'est dit et finalement dans
une affaire comme ça m'a coûté de
l'argent ça a payé les gens que j'ai
employé mais moi j'ai rien gagné c'est
en son honneur
toile et dans le cou décorateur saison
grâce à toi toi olsen est dans le coup
ça faisait comme assistant puis c'est
quelqu'un qui chante divinement l'opéra
au tout quand on boit un joli vert au
moins que quelqu'un anthony le suivi de
la traviata ces deux immenses et quand
cette traviata le bourdon le chapitrage
un bataille 10 et le 11 juin à champ de
bataille
on inaugure le jardin à l'occasion de la
plage à bien ah ben ça c'est pas
possible de rater on m'a dit que de tous
les fabricants de vaisselle de luxe de
été ruiné parce que les princes arabes
maintenant se meubler chez ikea
est ce que c'est vrai ça je pense pas
franchement et toi ta soeur est morte
pendant le était dans la wehrmacht dans
le premier avion long septembre était
dans le fameux oui c'est sûr et dix
comme histoire elle était dans la tour
dans le premier avion allait te dans
l'avion était sur la touche le premier
imaginons peux pas croire ça gèle ou éco
d'elle elle partait de boston pour aller
à los angeles voir son fils qu'elle a
détourné et l'avion était détourné way
imagine d'associations arrivée comme se
séparant des cons c'est quoi ce film
avec mal que malkovich basso s'occupera
complètement loufoques et drôles qui
s'appelle amicaux qui joue
holmes qui a pendant des années fait
semblant d'être kubrick qui a embobiné
sous le monde et qui avait plein de
ressemblance t il n'y aura pas du tout
c'était le contraire de lui jeter un fou
puisque schizophrène d'alcoolisme jour
la clé physique uniquement non plus plus
va du tout mais comme kobe qui était un
homme très discret très discret personne
ne savait quoi ils avaient l'air oui les
gens imaginaient je sais pas comment
d'ailleurs parce qu'il était toujours
ivre mort il était de faire le contraire
de ça ni mais quand même il a embobiné
il a réussi en bim plein de gens
viendraient que le mec de catch me if
you can de spielberg quoi il sert au
concours aussi et moi j'en ai reçues il
n'ya pas longtemps dans une émission un
type s'appelle bourdin qui se fait
passer pour d'autres c'est toute sa vie
s'est fait passer pour d'autres c'est
quand même extraordinaire solliciter un
malade
sauf rennes qui a fini dans une maison
un scanner savait qu'il existait mais le
laisser ça l'amusé bien film là-dessus
et mal qu ils sont solides et c'est sûr
quand je sais pas là c'est bien trop
sévère ou jouent dans le film vous êtes
en ville mais tous les autres
personnages cdac des moments comme ça
parce que l'objet du 6 mai ce qui est
beau avec marisa les trois premiers
films 3d plus beaux films du monde
la filmographie icône culte à l'âme
nettement tout à la norme en tenant par
les deux chambres d'hôtes ou quoi elle
fait chants bretons de moi pourquoi moi
j'adore marisa qui est une amie
délicieuse mais les elfes et chambres
d'hôtes chez luchino visconti le premier
film c'est mort à venise après les faits
barry lyndon et la préfet cabaret je
veux dire que c'est très cabaret est il
sous d'aussi histoire j'ai beaucoup de
chance et 4 ailleurs
c'était robert peut plus être autrement
c'est écrit visconti qui dit un
journaliste en italie les paysans sa
fille ni paris ni conflit ni dit les
nobles ça finit par ni visconti alors le
journaliste va dire ça à fellini fellini
nice et visconti nikita lis à droite a
jamais fait de cinéma jérôme pas parce
que j'ai fait deux films deux bides avec
topor j'ai fait un film muet en noir et
blanc comique érotique
on était partis du principe que tu sais
charlie chaplin buster keaton et tout ça
les ligues morale à hollywood était
terriblement sévère et je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais non le cinéma
comique américain muet ya jamais de sexe
jamais jamais faty legros faty fatty
arbuckle klm qui l'avait
absolument voilà et donc avec topor à
jour on était devant le trou des halles
et buvait énormément tu sais arrive à
huit heures du matin on était encore en
train de des chapeaux des notre scénario
le garçon de café nous amener les
lunettes de soleil ça c'est vraiment les
soirées qui se regarde toi quand le
garçon kate et on a dit on va faire un
film comique érotique muet et donc il ya
des grosse [ __ ] en carton etc
c'était c'était un c'était comme si
charlie chaplin sont les des données
avec des personnages comme dans les
films de charlie chaplin marché non
jacques lang a libéré le film porno la
semaine où les sorties à la la la seule
on les sort la france a été envahie de
films porno où il y avait pas de
simulation et nos buts en carton et
l'autre film c'était quoi jean leboucher
là le boucher la star et l'orpheline
c'était avec michel simon et michel
simon ont tourné dans un hammam rue
saint-denis c'était un vieux philosophe
qui prenait des bains turcs et au moment
de tourner la prise il me dit je ne
tourne pas et je dis pourquoi il me dit
sicilia pas si on ne fait pas un petit
câlin je fais pas la mise
on a été chercher une fille on a été
chercher une fille on attendu 3 droit 3
draps il s'est fait faire le petit câlin
et après la tournée après on a été
mangés au petit risque ou ses biens et
fuji michel vous voulez quoi peu comme
comme salaire on disait qu'il était
radin simon c'est totalement faux il m'a
dit donne moi mille francs pour acheter
des graines pour mes oiseaux
1 c'est beau et alors on lui fait un
chèque de 1000 francs en bois bien sûr
de ce qu'on avait plus un rond il ne l'a
jamais déposé jamais déposé mais moi je
fais pas de cinéma parce que le cinéma
c'est un en préparation un an de après
il faut faire la promotion vous faire
quinze mille entrées au
saint-andré-des-arts cetab le théâtre ce
qui est formidable alain robert nous on
fait des cartons tu sais on veut les
centaines de ministres
et quand on fait un bide au mont n'ya
pas passer trois ans un on ya passé
quinze jours un robert 20 jours un peu
près mémoire
tu as tu prépares robert qu'elle se
prépare chose incroyable audit lors du
clasico oui mais papa tu vas faire la
course de chars au palais des sports
pour stade de france 70 mille personnes
noires 6 500 mille spectateurs on ne
sait si non c'est trop bien oui c'est
pas mauvais et essayer de l'oeuf entier
2006 il n'en serait rien si on est mûr
abener tu sais qui tu dois apprendre
pour être sûr que le public sache lequel
ces ben-hur parce que moi j'ai vu carmen
vous allez où carmen avait 300 personnes
tu prends zidane et puis c'est tout
comme messi parce que zidane c'est sûr
que reconnaissons le reconnaîtra en plus
il est beau comme un dieu mais vous
allez tous ces mecs là sont des murs en
plus tu es vu une personne au stade de
france tu les vois pas tues mais il a de
tout seul et tout le monde le voit mais
bien entendu mais c'est vous qui avez un
conseil que se donne si tu veux tous les
cas j'adore ce que fait les éditions
assouline
les livres sont tellement bien choisie
c'est tellement des bonnes idées à
chaque fois c est rens et c'est très
réussi vraiment de
sans rien avoir de faire des livres
d'imagés vues enfin ce qu'on appelle les
beaux livres des livres de textes en
fait c'est des vrais production quand on
est on entame un livre de presse de
d'image comme ça on a des équipes qui
sont de si cette personne oui c'est
beaucoup de choses nous arriver à gagner
votre vie sur cela écoutez j'essaye de
ne pas le savoir
je n'ai jamais porter un soutien gorge
de ma vie ça va bien vous avez jamais
aujourd'hui non plus jamais je ne peux
pas je ne supporte pas jamais comme jane
fonda
mais quand même c'est la seule chose qui
me reste du cinéma et maryline et
marilyn a assez du cedus et du prix
alors c'est du bullshit
alors ça c'est clair absolument non
celle chantée du bris que l'on prend
j'aime beaucoup nadine en tous les cas
les questions tous les gens que j'ai
découvert nadine à monsieur vraiment sa
vie son histoire son destin sans vie peu
c'est une histoire qui riche
d'enseignements plus belle histoire loin
s'entend bien mais je crois qu'on finira
ensemble c'est mon rêve
je serai votre ashton kutcher je voulais
dit déjà je rêve de notre ashton kutcher
sera décoré par yannick garcia nous fera
une petite une petite folie comme ça
j'ai essayé dans les années 80 une
petite schlumbergera qui se s'est pas
bien passé je peux me refaire avec une
rothschild
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de béatrice
aussi mais voilà c'est le produit appelé
tout de suite en baisse quand même là
que je veux pas être une camélia non
pacsés ont pas question une seconde est
bon mon mari a mis 30 ans pour le faire
montrant temps pour faire ce qu'il
disait que c'était plus difficile de
faire un fromage que tueur du vin si
vous vous dire quand même c'est qu'il ya
500 ans d'âge qui ont été tués oui je
les connais une minute de silence
silence pour ses 500 pages à cause de la
vache folle il ya une image qui est
malade il est touché ça chez les
rothschild et tu es tu 500 vaches c'est
qu'ils rigolent pas là bas est en fait
cette vache n'était pas n'était pas
refuser une autorisation les 500 vaches
la nuit nuit pour ne pas justement que
les gens puissent c'était dramatique
mais dramatique on a eu des dépressions
nerveuses sauvage on nous a refusé de
faire un deuxième test et quelques mois
après ils ont ils envie que la lâche
était pas malade en parlant de bris
nadine si on parlait un peu politique
vous savez le khalife général de gaulle
quand il a perdu le référendum ce qui va
peut-être arriver bientôt
il a dit comment voulez vous que quand
qu'on puisse gouverner un pays où il ya
562 fromage 12
il est remarquablement bien a fait le
questionnaire de pouce vous êtes très
vite faire le jeu par toi le principal
trait de son caractère la spontané c'est
vrai et vous thierry l'opiniâtreté la
qualité que je préfère chez un homme y
en a quelques-unes karin viard m'avait
répondu une grosse m je parle de karin
viard jamais toi elle n'a jamais tourné
à kubrick en même temps
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit que la qualité
que je préfère c'est la nana une grosse
[ __ ] mais en même temps mais c'est
karine viard c'est pas marisa berenson
jamais tourner avec kubrick jeu
maintenant l'église continue alors que
je déteste ça quelqu'un qu'elle y aura
quelqu'un qui ose dire un truc pareil
tout ça mais on tue au nahd on vous aime
pas les deux buts ça donc je mens non
m'attend mais pour moi c'est un petit
pas publiquement chez nokia triche je
dire des tas de voir une représentation
d'un laurent blanc ce soir je déteste
karin viard de la qualité que vous
désirez c'est ana marisa il ya plusieurs
j'aime la télé gens j'aime la
sensibilité j'aime la profondeur d'un
j'aime
sentant la mauricie alors moi c'est la
responsabilité chez un homme pendant la
responsabilité chez elle si vous m'aviez
composer la question vous n'avez pas
encore posé la qualité vous préférez
c'est un homme machine tu cesses
justesse chez une femme se met moi la
femme
je suis amoureux des femmes c'est vrai
je pense qu'elles sont supérieurs à
l'homme c'est vrai à tous points de vue
quand les russes ont bombardé grosse ni
et que la ville était rasé comme dressed
on parle beaucoup de dress de mes
grosses lee a été rasé les seuls qui
sortait des caves les femmes c'était les
femmes pour aller chercher de l'eau pour
que les bébés ne meure ben ouais j'aime
les femmes j'aime la femme
robert ce que j'aime c'est que tu es
chrétien dramatiquement et ça me plaît
c'est ce que j'ai dit au parlement
quand il nous a reçus parce que nous
avions été dans le livre corps guinness
des évangiles de dieu pas du christ est
alors les rencontres et s'est fait
photographier avec ça calme et apôtres
il se parlait russe avec lui puisqu'ils
parlent très bien rue et un jour il me
dit tout tous croient au dieu toi et je
lui ai dit je crois tellement qu'il
finira bien par exister et lui je lui
dis et vous enseignant il m'a et
produits je crois en dieu parce que je
crois dans les hommes
mais
et non
[Musique]
au premier degré la vraie foi oui il ya
un grand poète polonais dont j'ai oublié
le nom car il faut pas se préoccuper de
savoir s'il ya un au delà
mais ici de se priver de savoir si un
avancé a quelque chose à dire je le dis
dans mon spectacle
l'important ce n'est pas de savoir le
jour on va mourir mais il est sûr qu'on
va vivre jusqu'à ce jour
noise à l bonsoir merci
bonsoir voulait me confier vos vêtements
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
elles sont mignonnes vous appelez qui
n'a émané comme afrique et didon
mignonne tes filles mes filles qui
arrivent se sont pas mises en avant en
tenue de soirée 100
oui mes chéris veut les meilleurs il dit
je trouve très nature d'avenir alors je
vais vous dire une chose c'est mon
anniversaire ce soir
joyeuse
elle
ouais
ils s'aiment
johanne hébert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une année entière vous soit douce et
casseurs et cacher c'est très tard à des
tournois et la belle-aide samia tout à
richard canny km à pied vous faire un
cadeau très très rare et poly vraiment
que ça figure que je réserve vraiment
pour les grosses circonstances mais
nadine vous mériter ça attention la
truite de schubert en allemand in einem
bericht à elle d'acheter aussi mme frot
à al hilal michaud forel faux rugby and
filed in steinberg est en crise ait eu
ce gros deals irish corner barbie en
fait dit la niche fort elles sont
réservées
je ne fais que l'on est grande c'est
constant mes enfants ma femme mes amis
savent que c'est exceptionnel ce soir
nadine je suis franchement j'ai traduit
en français la chanson qui la chantait
tout à l'heure que c'est une d'un dîner
à champ de bataille les quatre princesse
très chic
puisse t chiant comme tout elle était
venue pour faire des photos pour point
de vue marche qu'à l'oral chandon que
l'atout du jour oui bon choix
bonsoir c'est l'ennemi avec marty
mme au quatrième étage il vous plait
[Musique]
j'ai chanté ça on savait pas on connaît
ça je peux voulait traduire en français
et puis j'ai chanté une des chansons
qu'on chantait nous aux arts décoratifs
la grosse [ __ ] à dudu la suisse à nous
en recul
[Musique]
à
quand tu l'as à genève
salut
m
ses deux fils d'aidé consentie et du
coup je sais que tu sais que nadine été
ta voix l'olympia avec son attaquant
lhadji bien sûr moi je sers un court
après la vie moi la vie me court après
bien des gens font de feuilly moi c'est
folie de m'avoir fait rire ah la la
[Musique]
pour que lui
avec m
un peu tu
pourquoi at-on atteint agm st leu
m
[Musique]
bah ouais mais c'est mon dieu
j
du conseil willy meyer
balitsch floirac est l'outil dont tu
n'auras rare au pouce ni amant d'un soir
par l'onu
plus
amar faudra que je sois nommé marc coma
[Musique]
magalas
arthur t
[Musique]
je 5h30 jeux tiger woods c'est comme ça
dit il c'est génial de voir le fils dodi
constante y est non il a fait des films
avec ton père est ce qu'il y avait
si c'est vrai l'oiseau cas où est-il
dans ces crises ainsi les jours je suis
là et fleurs en l'attendant leurs études
ils comme moi quand tu étais
enfant mon enfant mon enfant c'est vrai
la terre
j ai longtemps j'ai cherché d'oiseaux
volent dans le monde
deux voleurs comme toi j'ai pleuré en
entendant mais devant mais pour toi j'en
suis sûr un beau jour
viendra
n'aie pas peur le soleil ne meurt pas
sous les ducs
il s'en va pour t'offrir a bouclé et
pourquoi
voudrais-tu s'envoler
il en levant
j'ai voulu moi aussi et j'ai des choux
blanc mon enfant thuir à bien plus loin
que le jour
[Musique]
l'oiseau bleu c'est l'amour là
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tabac c'est pas bon pour la voix et
chatin 7 le whisky c'est pas bon pour le
foie quand entité pc fatal pour le coeur
trois à la fois ya pourtant rien de mes
segat et whisky et p'tites pépées nous
laisse groggy et nous rendent sous cinq
cigarettes whisky est petit et paix et
c'est ça la vie et c'est bon les mêmes
c'est toujours un petit penchant pour
les femmes qu'elle soit brune qu'elle
soit blanc de chaque fois moi j'ai le
coeur
qui s'enflamme
et souvent lorsque j'ai deux ans nice et
évidemment les femmes cependant moi et
moi je ne pourrais pas m'en passer par
les femmes elles conservées folie aux
plus jeunes comme aux plus
je suis alors merci je n'ai pas honte de
l'avouer ce et souvent imaginaires en vo
des résolutions sur des femmes jeudi
matin dans la mine je connais trop bien
la chanson
[Musique]
plus de femmes
oui mais voilà
viens tu as passé un petit pas une jolie
fille qui m'a regardé elle me sourit
et
tout est changé sans mais fini je suis
prêt à recommencer a mis tout mon avis
oui comme star trek
[Musique]
et navo à la vie
m
[Musique]
malouda
thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'attends pas que tu as aussi relate
que tu entendes une créature des rares
mais tout est pas une personne de péter
gentil avait une bêtise de dit venus et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu